-The Roots are gonna
start playing a song
one instrument at a time.
Taylor and I can buzz in
and guess as soon
as we know the song.
But if you guess wrong,
the other person
gets a chance to steal.
-Ugh. Treacherous.
-You can play --
-Crazy.
-You can play along at home.
Roots, let's hear the firs
song, whenever you're ready.
Oh, man.
♪♪♪♪
[ Beep ]
-"Oops!...I Did It Again,"
Britney Spears?
-No!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, wait, wait, wait!
♪♪♪♪
"Baby One More Time"
by Britney Spears!
Ohh!
-Oh, my gosh!
Come on!
Ugh! What did I say?
What did I say?
I said "Oops"?
-That's shameful.
-I thought that like --
-It's those chords.
-[ Vocalizing ]
-It's them max Martin chords
-Max Martin chords.
Gosh darn it! I'm so mad.
All right. Ugh.
Of course, Taylor's
gonna kill me at this.
All right.
Let's hear the next song.
♪♪♪♪
-Ohh!
[ Beeping ]
-♪♪ Da-na, na-na ♪♪
-I know it. I know it.
-[ Mumbling lyrics ]
"Pour Some Sugar On Me,"
Def Leppard!
-Ohh!
♪♪♪♪
Sorry, sorry. I don't even kno
the words. I'm like --
♪♪ Hit me like a bomb, the
then come on na-na-na ♪♪
♪♪ Na-na-na-na-na,
with a red iPhone ♪♪
A red iPhone?
-It's actually radar phone
-It's radar phone?
I thought it was a red iPhone.
-They were super ahead
of their time.
-"Trust me, in the future,
everyone's gonna have a red...
-This song came out in the '80s,
and they know about iPhones.
-Yeah, man, they're prescient.
All right, here we go.
Let's hear the next song.
♪♪♪♪
[ Beep ]
-It's Nelly,
it's Nelly, it's Nelly.
It's "Hot in Herre."
Ha!
-What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is my favorite song.
♪♪♪♪
-Ohh! How did you get that
Oh, my gosh.
-Yes.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Gosh. You are proving
that you're a genius.
Come on. How would you
guess that from that?
-Just, like, middle school
It imprints on you.
-"Hot in Herre." "Hot in Herre."
-Mm-hmm.
-Here we go.
Let's hear the next one.
♪♪♪♪
I'd love it
if you guessed it now.
♪♪♪♪
[ Beep ]
"Bad Guy," Billie Eilish.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Whew. All right.
Coming back. Coming back, man.
Whoo!
-Okay.
-There's a little bit --
That's a little bit of a lot
-Too much. Yeah.
Why don't you just say,
"You need to calm down"?
Just say it. All right.
Come on. I set you up.
I set you up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've had to learn
to say different versions
of common phrases like
"Shake it off."
-Yeah, you can't
say that anymore?
-"You need to calm down."
Like, I've had to figure out
how to not to say puns of
my own songs in conversation
I've gotten sort of good at it
-Let's hear the next song.
Here we go.
♪♪♪♪
-"Kiss Me,"
Sixpence None The Richer.
-Oh, my God! Yes!
♪♪♪♪
You even got the band?
♪♪ Kiss me ♪♪
Sixpence None The Richer.
You even got the band.
-That was the first song
I learned to play on guitar.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Me too.
All right.
Let's hear the next song.
-Okay.
♪♪♪♪
[ Beep ]
-Is it "No Scrubs"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-What the heck?
How did you guess that?
-It's the chords.
-Whoa!
-How did you get that?
-It's just chords in a song.
-Oh, my gosh.
It's the chords in the song.
-I'm really too excited.
I'm flushed and --
-I know. This is a fun game.
I really have met my match
-Really fun.
-This is unbelievable.
All right.
It's time for the final song
This is worth 10,000 points.
-Towards what?
-It's anyone's game.
Whoever wins this,
wins the whole game.
-Okay.
-Roots, take it away,
whenever you're ready.
♪♪♪♪
[ Beep ]
-"Shake It Off"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughs ] Yeah!
I'm sorry. No, no, no. Come on
Oh, I love it!
That's my favorite thing
that ever happened
on the whole show ever.
Taylor Swift, everybody.